In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
Though reading, from the Sinaxadion, for October 5, on which we commemorate, our venerable
Father Gregory of Kahnsta in Georgia, St. Gregory, who came of a noble family, was adopted
and brought up at court by his aunt, the wife of Granduke Nurses of Kartli in central
Georgia, while her husband was a prisoner of the Arabs in Baghdad in the years 770-780.
All his kindred were amazed at Gregory's abilities in divinity, philosophy, and foreign
tongues, but above all at his piety.
From birth he had been consecrated to God, and indeed lived like a monk in prayer and
fasting, and in the avoidance of every worldly diversion.
His princely relatives persuaded him to receive ordination to the priesthood, but gathering
that the intention was to consecrate him Bishop Soon Afterwards, Gregory fled with four other
young noblemen to the south of Georgia.
He got as far as the poor and humble monastery of Opisa in Ajarya, where they spent two years
in obedience and mortification.
Gregory often visited the hermits who lived in the surrounding mountains, and did his best
to follow the examples of virtue that he saw among them.
The consta region to the southwest had been ravaged by Arab raids, and by a cholera epidemic.
An aged hermit living in those parts had a vision that led Gregory to obtain the blessing
of his abbot, to go with his companions, to establish a monastery there.
As soon as they reached the place, they planted a cross in the earth, and straight away began
to build a wooden church, surrounded by separate cells for the brethren.
The work was hard in the extreme, but even so their life continued to revolve around prayer
and the praise of God.
So before long, Gregory became a chosen vessel of grace, whose virtuous renown drew the faithful
to the monastery in large numbers from all over Georgia.
But he would receive into the brotherhood only those among them who were humble, teachable,
willing to work zealously at the acquisition of the virtues and to submit to the martyrdom
of obedience.
Gabriel, who ruled in that region, was a pious and god-fearing man.
He invited Gregory to his house and asked him to bless his children.
From then on, he became the fervent protector of the monastery.
He had the church built of stone at his own cost, and spoke highly of the virtues of the man
of God.
To the founder of the Bagratid dynasty, Prince Ashott, Kuru Palates, in the years 780-826, who
supported by the Roman Emperor had taken the lead in the mighty effort going on in that
part of southwest Georgia to throw off the Muslim yoke.
Gregory was given a most honorable reception at court, and large donations were made to his
monastery, which became the spiritual center of the country.
When the building works at the monastery were well-advanced, the saint set out on pilgrimage
to Constantinople, once he brought back many relics, icons, and precious objects.
He also sought to the compilation of a tipicon for his monastery, and its dependencies, based
on that of the lava of Saint Sabhas.
Gregory's authority in the land was such that his word was decisive on all matters of importance.
The princes feared his censure, and wishing to consecrate their sons to God entrusted them
to his care.
Several of his disciples became bishops, most notably Ephrem, bishop of Adskar and primate
of Satskeh, and are senior the great who supported by Gregory became Catholicos of Georgia.
One day Prince Ashot's successor, unvisiting the monastery of Kanshta, exclaimed,
"'We forget we are on earth here, and believe we are with the saints in heaven.'"
As the years passed, Saint Gregory came to preside over twelve monasteries in the region,
which became known as the Georgian Sinai.
He appointed the abbots of all these foundations of which he retained the oversight.
But he never ceased to be the spiritual father of all the monks, expounding to them the sacred
books and canonical discipline with the help of his extraordinarily attentive memory.
He resisted repeated efforts to make him a bishop and a bird that the churches of the desert
are also seats of the divine glory, and not inferior to the thrones of this world.
One day, an airing bishop whom Gregory had rebuked, bribed a bowman to ambush the saint
on his way back to the monastery.
When Gregory appeared on the road, the man saw above him a column of light reaching up to
the sky and a luminous cross like a rainbow resting upon his head.
The man was terror-stricken, he dropped his bow and running forward through himself
at the feet of the saint who forgave him.
The bishop was enraged when he learnt his plot had failed and tried to destroy the monastery,
but God punished him, and he came to a wretched end.
Gregory was so strengthened by the power of Christ that he reached the age of 102 years
with no loss of health, yet earnestly desired to make his way to the Lord.
He had candles distributed to all the monks in his monasteries and let them know the day
that they should like them and make intercession for his eternal memory.
On the 5th of October, in the year 861, as he was giving final counsels to his disciples,
he appeared suddenly illumined by a light beyond all utterance.
Angels surrounded him, and after he had made the sign of the cross over his monastery,
his soul was welcomed in heaven by a voice that proclaimed,
blessed art thou among the heirs of the glory and everlasting joy.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.